those who pulled tiger woods from this
crash
say he's lucky to be alive but it's
unclear if his
injuries could force an end to the
golfer's sporting career
police are calling this an accident not
a crime
the first officer to arrive at the scene
found no evidence that golfer was
intoxicated
or impaired but says woods appeared
unaware
of the gravity of his condition tiger
woods was rescued through the windscreen
the exterior of the suv severely
battered
after it rolled several times the
protected interior
and seat belt is credited with saving
the golfer's life
this section of road is said to be
notorious for accidents
and tiger woods it's understood was
driving downhill at speed
when his suv lost control his injuries
were said to be so
serious no impairment tests were done at
the scene
as he was rushed to a trauma center for
emergency surgery
we've learned a metal rod has been put
in the golfer's injured right leg
and screws and pins are reinforcing his
ankle and foot
now in recovery the long-term impact of
these injuries
are still unknown the muscles they have
to get strong
we have to work on coordination so he's
in a machine
that's a finely tuned machine and so
it's the muscles
and the rotation of the body parts and
the creation of momentum
these are all the things that allow him
to do what he does so that's going to
take a much longer time than just the
six to eight weeks for the bones to heal
tiger woods come back from rock bottom
with a masters win in 2019
has been described as something from a
film
many don't want this crash to be the
scene that ends his sporting career
without tiger woods out there i think
something would be lacking i think that
most golfers after a couple of back
surgeries would have said you know what
i'm done with this i can't do it anymore
but yet he's got four of them and then
now he's got this latest set back with
this accident
if there's any individual in the world
that can come back from this it's
certainly tiger
it's unclear how long the golfer will
remain in hospital or if he'll ever play
again
but one thing many know is a comeback
should never be discounted for tiger
woods
sally lockwood sky news los angeles